pushing pushing and pushing and same
thing as
yesterday you're going to feel
tension just release it that's your ex
that's your exercise release it but I
don't want you to do it externally I
don't want you to move okay you do it
inside without moving it
then you'll do the other side
okay and when you do it don't want you
to make your hand go like this keep keep
the metatarsal spreading but not tension
okay just it's like a soft a very very
very soft
v just keep
releasing if you if you feel your
partner is really getting it then you
start shoving like really hard and you
try to like okay tension here and I'll
release it again
okay if they're not however then stick
with the kind of gradual if you feel it
about to break you know then hold it at
that max level
okay okay so again shape is has nothing
to do with tension so he he's he's going
to drive and I'm going to move and not
be tempted to tense so the same feeling
that I'm able to get here I keep that
moving okay I'm going to do the outward
spiral so my elbow is going to trade
places
elbow okay he's pushing really really
hard I sink everything release
everything and then my elbow Ive okay I
don't lose
anything so meaning I don't have that
you see but I don't start this either
he's he's driving just like last R find
the last R let it
sink keep the sink feeling and the elbow
starts the outward SP
okay all we're
doing we'll feel it everyone feels it
release in the release sinking State
start the spiral
don't don't worry about him it's the
movement
inside just push push push push p
okay let's
try and now he's going to pull he's
going to pull okay and you're going to
do the same thing
S I don't I don't want you to get that
positive angle you see in your back okay
you're just everything's going to sink I
don't want the shoulder to come forward
we hold the same posture
let go of the tension pay attention to
the lower
body okay let's try
he's doing that same
tool you're going to ground the same way
and you're going to do the inward
SP in the same pause
P sink and don't worry about him do the
movement you're in your body so in other
words I feel myself going like that I
feel the tension in my body as a
reaction of losing balance I'm going to
release the tension release the tension
okay and the same way as I start to move
I I can feel myself tense I don't tense
I keep sinking sinking sinking and I
move my elbow wrist Co okay is there
there this part I just sink and then I
move
that
coil sink sink
sink loose
loose sink tension
free move the coil in your body okay
here we
go all right so we had push and pull and
they're they're dealt with the same way
you just sink okay so it doesn't really
matter if he's pushing or
pulling um so we are going to add uh
we'll go back to a spinal displacement
okay and same thing I ground it all the
same releasing I'm going to work
everything the same
uh I'm going to add movement to it now
okay so as I start to move I don't want
to start tensing
okay so I do the same thing I'm going to
start adding movement to it just a
simple movement
going to this angle here
okay so I'm in
Sea okay ground that start the spiral
this creates this Zone here and that's
where I move first this leg then I come
up on my feet okay and we're just stop
here you can you can dve does
matter side again he's pushing pushing
pushing
pushing okay he's pushing I sink it I
start to spiral this way I go to the
outside of it open the knee seek
Kiza and we'll have him he's still
pushing that whole time
okay oh this is the opening I want open
the leg
seea he's still pushing doesn't
matter come around and we're going to
stop
here okay
again he's driving drive drive drive
drive drive drive okay sink okay uh
maybe come this angle so you can see
that I I don't want to move like this
you see cuz I'm I don't have the angle
cancellation I'm on the inside of his
arm and then you're available
here it's a very small detail but as he
pushes this energy goes out way then I
go here this is difficult for a lot of
people cuz he's he's thrusting like that
and so you go like that but it's not
true okay so I can move now okay now I
hold
this again ground his energy start the
ouward spiral then you can move to the
outside you don't lose that Integrity
you can't push that
arm not even if I'm moving then you keep
that
[Music]
Center and as you go to same thing is he
pushes release sink move
move move same thing here don't
start just stay
released through his
body tension free
and right now I'm staying in his
shoulder
okay when I do this throw it's going to
stay in his shoulder right there
okay let's
try we're going to do two things here
now uh so as as I do that part there
that's that's where the atmi comes in
okay it chy doesn't go go like
that here boom
okay now he either does nothing and gets
hit which is fine doesn't matter okay
but as you go on you use that you use
that head you use that
head you're going to add here at the
head if he blocks if he blocks it then
you're going to use you're going to use
the
Hat don't just let it be dead do you
understand okay so I'm doing the same
thing that's what we're doing doing
doesn't matter what he does okay and
then the next thing we're going to do is
I'm going to stop being in the shoulder
I'm going to be down down there okay
that's what I want down here in the
center e
there same thing
okay let's
try okay and now we'll do the same thing
and he's pull he's pulling like before
okay he pulling like before I I do every
everything the same everything the
same it doesn't matter no no no
sink
Center stay relaxed
okay let's
go all right so uh as I as I push and he
is
going here is where he has my Center he
has my Center because I'm contesting
here okay in in other words he's got
positive uh positive y to my y Okay so
what I'm going to do is get my Center
out of this by coming to the other side
so if we were let's just go a little
smoother okay so he
goes and I get my Center out you see
just simply by taking my hand go ahead
from here and moving it
here inside the
circle which is what you would do if you
wanted to trap and and reverse the
technique
J
so again what I what I did there slow is
I came here you see out of that movement
first so here I'm trying to free my
Center okay boom up and then you'll you
you will feel it die
but because he has my Center originally
here he's got it already then you get
here
okay okay let's
try okay so he's gonna have your Center
do you see gonna have some
Center you
see
[Music]
push what are you doing braing racing so
that's not the art
so get a
push you're going to do the
you're going to do the
technique hell
Set It
Off come
on feel the difference yes
that's
very soft
hey doesn't check
me hey I can touch the m without
detention
so here we
go you will have some Center I will have
some Center I'm not going to go in your
shoulder there some
Center
bracing
so come in
leave e
hey he
uh
so what we're doing here is as I feel
you have my Center we gone back to
disconnection and
bracing I'll get out of
it not
bracing not
disconnection you see the difference yes
sensei
okay for
different right yes s
say TR
so we're really doing the same stuff
it's just from the other side now St
okay so again it looks like you can just
step through right and then the then the
instructor has to go like hey you would
never give your back you know they
create some narrative what I'm saying is
is you can't step through because at
that point they're going to have your
Center so as you try to move that
knee it's not going to go through it's
like you'll have to go you have to get
that
off and then we have the the bent arm
TI and then I'm going just enter okay so
those are our Catch 22 so you'll
feel he's got it you want to you
want to keep doing that you see you
can't do that cuz you get you don't have
the
uh the M Integrity the guy just going to
close and really what happens is this
one becomes the strike as we know okay
so you'll have to can't
bend cuz you're you're not moving
you got what you got to deal with okay
so I'm going to help you don't fight it
don't run from it both of those are the
same
okay you're pushing remember okay so
there's that got it let it move
you good and you go around it keep your
extension got it without push without
pushing checking hey checking can I go
in though no is the difference can I go
in no okay but you're not trying to push
on
me so so you feel it I go
here and then I go like this it's like
whoa what happened to the throws where
he's going across the M
okay so there is some movement I'm going
to show you that part first okay
you're in my get out of my shoulder get
in my Center
lower okay so you look how I'm moving
you see you see
that not
here turn there's some
movement here you see the arm lengthens
and then on
here there's absorption moove me
right feel how we see okay right there's
a there's a right there on the
edge as you
go I move and roll out pressure is off
high can't get that in can't get that in
in my Center lower there you go
pressure so we be in there that KNE is
what you don't
want absorb with the
knee when you feel the pressure on the
center absor absorb with the knee more
till it's off now you start to go around
it yeah so but don't lose extension okay
so for example stand
up you're here you're driving your
UK uh how far do I step back or deviate
it depends to what what do I try to find
zero point zero
pressure so you push right and I move to
zero
pressure I
draw I move to zero pressure
come
on zero
pressure
five okay so CL a clarification all
right as as he goes and I'm going to
feel whoa do you see
I got I got to go to zero pressure and
then I got to deconstruct the projection
point this what you do in all of two
home okay so are going to go here's
where that leg moves do you think but
you still have the projection Point
you're going to get me so I have to do
both but this leg is
movable and it moves to zero pressure
okay now you can put your hand here but
my hand here is not what's keeping my
this hand in place there's zero pressure
if this hand is bracing to keep my hand
and your hand in place then I'm not at
zero pressure you see I need
to get to zero pressure okay but this is
now for balance which is just
fine off you see how off it goes yes you
go really fast
off you go your
fastest off you see yes you just hit air
okay try it